Donald Trump's former White House
communications director Anthony
scaramouche II has again admitted
something which I've been covering for
years at this point which is that Donald
Trump has difficulty reading he really
doesn't read and he struggles to read
Anthony scaramouche II has been doing
interviews recently he's been more
honest than maybe we are used to hearing
from people who worked for Trump or who
worked for Trump and he's admitted to a
number of things including that Donald
Trump can't read very well check out
this clip from an interview with Anand
Giridhar das who's been a previous guest
on the David Pakman show as well I'm not
I'm not I'm not a diagnostician but my
guess is that he probably had an
undiagnosed learning disability as a kid
maybe it's a form of dyslexia or
something like that and so his reading
comprehension levels are not where his
IQ possibly is okay now he's in decline
right now but you'd have to stipulate
that he's a reasonably smart guy I mean
he built a business he built a
television show he had made a name for
himself and in 17 short months he went
from being a reality television star to
the presidency of the United States so
we have to stipulate that there's
intelligence in there but it's what kind
of intelligence so scaramouche he is
obviously not saying it in as definitive
or aggressive terms as we have suggested
before but scaramouche we also knows
that Trump struggles to read and he
makes it clear there this is not making
fun of people this is not making fun of
learning disabilities this is simply
pointing out don't we need a president
who can read well and regularly reads we
suspect Trump hasn't read a book in his
adult life there's no evidence that
Trump has read a book in his adult life
he's never mentioned reading anything
other than his own book art of the deal
which he didn't write Tony Schwartz
wrote it and the Bible which you know if
you believe Trump reads the Bible okay I
may have a bridge to sell you but
remember that I've been covering this
for years and there's interest in it and
a lot of agreement back in February of
2017 we did a story called Trump fails
basic literacy test it got nearly 3.4
million views on YouTube another 7 mm
on Facebook this was subsequently picked
up around the world including in France
in other countries and it explains a lot
now not being able to read well doesn't
mean Trump's a bad person not being able
to read well doesn't mean Trump is wrong
on policy he is usually wrong on policy
but for other reasons but it explains a
lot to quote Donald Trump including
things like this from earlier this week
Dickinson whole logic and Cephei sefa
hide this reading deficit has been
widely corroborated Saturday Night
Live's Pete Davidson said when Trump was
hosting SNL Trump couldn't seem to read
the scripts I've played this clip for
you before what happened with the Trump
star guy so he's like he doesn't really
know how to read for real yeah and he
loves to improv yes
so during like the table read he liked
before like we were gonna read eat
before he had to read each line and he's
the host so he's at everything yeah he
would go I'm not gonna say this I think
I'm gonna say it the way I want to say
is it okay do you okay Lauren everything
that everybody's like what and then this
is my favorite part is there was a
sketch that we wrote where he's at
Disneyland with his daughter and the
line is uh alright let's get out of here
turkey legs like let's like go get
turkey legs and he he doesn't know to
read so he went all right let's get out
of here turkey legs
[Laughter]
he doesn't get it like he thinks if
everybody's laughing with him but we're
all laugh I got him so that's not new
we've covered that previously no casler
worked with Trump on The Apprentice and
says Trump couldn't read although with
no casler it seemed maybe it was more
about Trump's inability to sit still
rather than simply not being able to
read no casler you know we've heard
about the possible uppers stuff with The
Apprentice so the point is we know from
sources inside the White House Trump's
presidential daily briefings have been
reduced from what snore
many pages of text - just a couple of
pages - just one page - just one page
that is half charts and graphs and even
that Trump is accepting with low
frequency so this is not good and the
reason it's not good is because it's
tough to be informed if you're not
reading a lot as president that's how
Barack Obama was informed that's how
George George W Bush read a lot he read
a you know political material he also
just read books we know that doesn't
mean Bush is a great guy doesn't mean he
was a great president but he was reading
at least he came to many wrong decisions
but he was reading
Bill Clinton spent a ton of time reading
intelligence reporting books etc Trump
simply doesn't do it and all politics
aside that's a fundamental liability
when you're president of the United
States
it's sad more than anything but it has a
real effect on Trump's ability to be a
leader and it's not a good effect I'll
tell you that right now there's a
YouTube channel called up flip that
we're partnering with I would love for
you to check it out I've put the link
right underneath the video make sure to
subscribe to the channel when you're
there up flip is a channel that is all
about exploring small business and what
makes a small business successful every
episode interviews an entrepreneur you
take a tour of the business and these
are not generic interviews you actually
get a really fascinating deep dive into
the history of the business the mistakes
the entrepreneur made what they learned
what motivates them what a day is like
running their business and you get all
sorts of super interesting and valuable
insight about what it's like to run that
type of small business as a business
owner myself I find up flips videos to
be endlessly intriguing even if you
don't own your own business it is really
great for a general audience it's stuff
that I think just about anybody would
find fascinating and you can check it
out by going to david pakman.com slash
up flip the link is right underneath
this video when you're there make sure
to subscribe and click the bell for
notifications